foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb Cassius
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Alice number one best-selling author and
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you are just joining us this
week yesterday we launched the gazelle
debit card brought to you by Ramsey
thank you to the thousands and thousands
and thousands of you that have already
registered and already gone and gotten
the app and applied and we're getting
your gazelle cards printed now to you
immediately this is the debit card that
helps you spend and save the Ramsey way
no we're not becoming a bank believe me
I don't want all those regulations but
there is a bank that does this and we're
the front end skin of it uh marketing so
to speak and uh Hey it comes with a
debit card a spending account a mobile
app and it connects seamlessly with
every dollar be sure and check it out
already got people in the lobby holding
theirs up it is by far the coolest
looking debit card ever made and that's
really not an exaggeration it is it's
really sharpened it's very sharp I mean
the gazelle looks pretty intense
we told told the audience yesterday we
talked about putting a a red eye in him
but he looked like a devil dog then so
he didn't do the red eye and because he
didn't want a devil dog we wanted a
gazelle and so uh but it's made for you
guys and you know some of these cards
are they got more fees than a French
poodle I mean it's Fifi Fifi Fifi Fifi
everywhere and we got we don't have all
those fees okay we don't feed you to
death We're not gonna try to make money
off of you selling you debt we don't run
a nice commercial with pretty little
people and then get you 22 in debt like
so far does we're just really gonna just
help you handle your money with a debit
card it's real simple so go to
ramsesolutions.com gazelle you can get
started it's certainly free to start
your account and uh it we're not gonna
hit you with so many fees that you think
you're a French poodle so just be ready
you're gonna love it you're gonna love
it it's pretty incredible it's a and you
know kind of when you but when you you
know you do your groceries with this or
you're out in public you're kind of
making a statement you know like like I
am in control of my money I'm not
spending like I'm in Congress you know
know I mean it's just like your little
gazelle card just says I'm I'm part of
the tribe man and uh it's all free you'd
electronically transfer your stuff in
it's FDIC insured so be sure you don't
miss out ramseysolutions.com gazelle you
can get started the big public launch
was yesterday and uh so you're seeing it
everywhere
including the front page of the fox
website from an interview George and I
did yesterday morning that they've
already popped up there thank you fox
and Fox Business we appreciate the
coverage so tons of good things going on
all right let's jump to the phones Nick
is with us in Virginia hi Nick welcome
to the Ramsay show
uh thank you Dave thank you Christina I
got my gazelle card a few weeks ago I'm
holding up the high right now
all right we need to put like a light on
it so you can hold it up like a cell
phone right have a concert all right
what's up man how can we help
yeah Dave so I'm moving from DC to
Greenville South Carolina
um we're looking to buy a home in
December and then selling our current
home in DC in February I've listened to
the real estate reality check I read the
blog post I think you put out a month
like a month after that I'm just still
worried you know
um it might sound ridiculous but I just
I'm still worried about housing prices
crashing getting stuck in between two
houses everything like that I'd love to
hear some more of your thoughts on that
and some more reassurance
well I mean
since Washington continues to layer
stupid upon stupid there's a lot of
reason for us to uh
uh be a little worried I mean it's you
know you just keep watching them I mean
how many more dumb things can you people
do up there
um and so I not you personally but I'm
just saying DC you know the the
politicians the freaking White House has
lost its mind economically it's the
worst economy inflation wise in 40 years
so yeah I can understand you being
concerned I mean I kind of look over my
shoulder and I know the data and I'm
real comfortable with the facts but your
emotions do creep up on you I don't
blame you for that I I can understand
that
um I went and talked to one of my
friends as a custom home builder this
weekend and he goes
yeah it changed because I got no
customers
they were lined up around the block and
he's got no customers so um yeah it's
changed and he's talking about stuff
building that building stuff next summer
you know that kind of a thing uh uh a
year from now and so that which is not
far from your time frame so but all that
to say
yeah I emotionally agree with you but
the facts are still there
there is still four buyers for every
house that's up for sale
uh the facts recent data as you know I
read two articles on the air yesterday
George and I did that um that are coming
out with fresh data even out of
California which is really experiencing
some problems because of the mass Exodus
um and we've got a California Refugee
problem in Tennessee and so um
uh but the uh uh you know there still is
affecting things but the uh uh the data
Nationwide for Greenville South Carolina
and for uh Arlington Virginia is still
that there's about four buyers for every
house that's for sale uh now that
they're not as active and they're not as
frenzied as they were but that was an
unusual frenzy for about two and a half
years we went through there
I've been in the real estate business
since 1978 I've never seen people act
like that before
usually it takes about 90 days to sell a
house and you're going to get a couple
of offers and none of them are full
price you know and that's a normal house
selling process over the last 40 or 50
years you're going to experience that
and you don't have to rush over and
overpay for something when you get to
Greenville South Carolina you're going
to be able to walk around look at houses
and make an offer and think about it and
you know use a normal buying process too
now what I would do and I would do this
in any economy is I would not buy a
house until yours is sold
yeah that's what I was wondering what is
the what's the reasoning for buying a
December and selling in February
just the slow process of moving my
wife's wrapping up her job so it's
that's really
um she's from Greenville South Carolina
so we know it very well I mean I've been
there probably once or twice every year
once or twice a year for the last 10
years so
um I just kind of want to do if you end
up with two house payments you're going
to become what's called a motivated
seller
oh
uh well the other house is almost paid
off so I can literally write a check
today and pay it off okay well if you
want to pay it off and sit on it but but
here's the thing even that with it
sitting up there empty and you're paying
taxes and insurance and utilities and
you got to keep it all nice and proper
so it can be shown uh you're going to
reach a point emotionally that you
become a motivated seller I want I want
rid of this thing I want that chapter of
my life closed so be real careful with
that because you I don't want you to
give it away because of the because you
create a situation for yourself
so I I personally would rethink that and
say I'm not buying until mine sells and
if that means you rent for six months in
Greenville or you do some other plan
uh you do some uh corporate housing in
Arlington because you sell the house out
from under yourself in December uh and
your wife has some things to close up
then that's fine but I'm going to change
the logistics to flip-flop on that where
I buy 90 days after I sell or at least
nine days after I sell and that'll take
a lot of stress off of this
hey good question man thanks for letting
us discuss it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys I want to share something
exciting our team has been working on
for well over a year we've built a brand
new debit card that helps you spend and
save the Ramsay way it's called gazelle
the gazelle debit card works the same as
your standard debit card with the same
FDIC protections provided by our bank
partner password n a member FDIC with
gazelle your privacy is important we
won't sell your personal information
which means you won't have debt pushed
on you imagine not having an inbox full
of credit card offers coming at you
every week the gazelle debit card
eliminates these distractions and helps
you attack your money goals fast plus it
offers benefits others don't like no
monthly fees and a seamless connection
with every dollar and did I mention we
won't push debt on you guys your money
is you your money you work hard your
gazelle intense and now your debit card
is too get the gazelle debit card and
take control of your money for good go
to ramseysolutions.com gazelle to sign
up that's
ramsesolutions.com gazelle
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Ellis Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
JW Is With Us in Atlanta hijw how are
you
hey however y'all better than we deserve
sir how can we help
so I just started listening to you about
a month ago
um I never really known about you or
anything and I'm trying to figure out
how much of a stupid but Millennial I am
and
what baby step that I'm on which way I
should be focusing my my gazelle
intensity uh I'm kind of lost at the
moment and I don't really know which way
to go
well tell us about your situation right
now
um do you have how much debt do you have
uh the only debt that I have is my house
I've never owned a credit card and I've
never bought anything that I couldn't
pay for okay well that sounds like a
good start telling us you may know a
stupid butt Millennial but you're not
one of them okay so we've already got
that ahead all right but I am curious
why why do you think you're making
stupid bad decisions
well I mean some of what you guys say is
you know I've always just kind of done
it off of common sense or what I
believed was coming since
um I'm not the smartest guy in the world
so I'm trying to figure out well the
only difference is I sell it
I know that you guys normally promote
paying off all your debt before you
start putting money into your 401k or
not counting your house college funds
I'm not counting your house your debt
free except your house you said right
yes sir okay
and I bought my house about five years
ago
um I owe about another five years and
it'll be paid off how old are you um
32. way to go dude you're killing it
yeah that's that's excellent so you
would be in baby steps four through six
right now which um it sounds like you're
investing right now how much are you
investing into retirement
I put 30 of my paycheck into my IRA okay
well we typically recommend 15 of your
income and then baby step five is paying
for your kids college do you have kids
yes ma'am okay so we'd want you saving
in a 529 plan and then paying off your
house early which it sounds like you're
already really motivated in doing that
you could you could just increase that a
bit take some of that 30 percent take 15
of that and throw that towards your
house but you're doing awesome okay yeah
the only fine tune we might do is turn
down your retirement a little bit down
to 15 make sure you're doing something
for your kids if you're not already and
dumping all right so the house might be
done in like three years
oh that'd be great because it stresses
me out big time and then if it was done
in like three years instead of five
years because you're only putting 15
retirements to the 30. you following me
if that happened then then you would be
at what we call baby step seven and when
you're there that's the last baby step
that's just build wealth and give and
you max out all retirement and you pile
up cash and you're outrageously generous
and you you know you've lived like no
one else and now you're ready to live
and give like no one else man I will say
JW you surprised me when you said stupid
about decisions I was ready for
something juicy
we were thinking you might be the color
of the week but no no you're just uh
you're just a just a smart guy I mean
you're way ahead of the curve yeah the
stuff we teach is common sense it's gods
and Grandma's ways of handling money it
lines up with what the scriptures teach
about money and what grandma are these
days great grandma because some grandmas
today ain't gain common sense but so
great grandma uh for sure it used to be
called common sense to live on less than
you make always have some money set
aside for an emergency always being you
know planning for the future called
retirement and kids college always be
avoiding debt if you can't pay for
something that means you don't need to
buy it
keeps you out of debt it's a um you know
it's a different mentality than uh 90
something percent of the public has
today and so uh Christina and I got a
big job right but the thing is it's not
complicated I think part of the reason
that he thought he wasn't winning with
money was because he's like this is
simple like I've been following these
principles and it's common sense since
it's simple I must be doing something
wrong but
but it really is simple well it's not
easy but if there is this thing out
there and it's been there for the Whole
30 years I've been on the air I've
noticed it is that
people there's
and I I actually have fallen prey to it
in the past not in a long long time but
there's this thing that if it's not
complicated it must not be good when it
comes to money like if it's real simple
it must be wrong because I mean it has
to be complicated if it's money has to
be hard to understand if it's money if
it's not sophisticated you know it must
be wrong and and the truth is the stuff
we teach and the stuff that works the
best is very easy to understand but hard
to do because you have to control the
idiot in your mirror
and the guy in my mirror is my problem
if I can get that out of behave he can
be skinny and Rich but he's got issues
and you know that's a problem I like
donuts that's a problem it's a problem
and so
um you know we all have this and you
know Rachel likes Amazon Prime click
click click click click the stuff keeps
showing up on her porch you know it's
like turn that thing off and so we all
do this stuff right and if we can
control our behaviors personal finance
is 80 Behavior that's why it feels like
it's
it should be harder it should be more
complicated but it but when you actually
face the demons it is hard because it's
the demons that are the problem it's not
the math the Math's easy right and uh
but yeah JW we always say around here
that uh common sense is so rare if you
get it it's like having a superpower all
right Noah is with us in Chicago hey
Noah what's up
hey thanks for taking my call
um just have a quick question
um my wife and I we have some some
student loans uh we have a Roth IRA with
an amount that could just about pay off
all of the student loans uh would you
recommend that we cash that out and and
just pay off the student loans and be
done with it nope
okay nope how much is in your student
loans
about thirty thousand and what's your
household income
um six figures well what's six figures
nine hundred thousand or a hundred and
five thousand
uh 120 000. okay good good for you well
done how old are you guys
uh we are 25. good for you okay I would
stop adding to your Roth IRA because
you've been aggressively investing while
not paying off your student loan
okay if you stop adding to your IRA and
stop adding to anything except attacking
these student loans they become your
singular mathematical Focus
do nothing but attack those things with
a freaking vengeance
like ah right
yeah and you're going to have those
things paid off in about 18 months if
you do that
okay 2500 a month you're done in a year
well in that feeling that you feel right
now that desire to quickly get it all
paid off that's a good feeling just use
that to turn it into gazelle intensity
to use that motivation to do the work
day in day out to knock out baby step
two and pay off those loans but the fact
that you feel that kind of gross feeling
where you're like ugh I want these out
of my life like lean into that and use
that as motivation yeah that's that's
exactly right you know when you have a a
you know
bottle whatever feelings you've got
negative or positive and point them at
these loans and that's you know it's
like anything where you're feeling real
positive but anything where you're
pissed off or scared you know aim it at
that and just and then get it get it get
after it stop all the stupid no going
out to eat no uh no vacations we're
cleaning this mess up these aren't pets
they're loans get rid of them
well y'all make good money so you can
knock this out pretty quick and the
sacrifices the not going out to eat
they're not going on vacation it's just
for a season and once these are gone
you're 25 years old you're going to have
such Freedom after that in time to
really invest I was cracking up we've
got these glass boards that are like
three feet by two feet that we have
outside the studio when people do their
debt free screams in the studio here are
in the lobby they sign you know there's
how much debt they paid their name the
date that kind of stuff and I was
walking and then we every time they get
full we move the glass boards and
they're all over the building from all
the years of the debt free scream so our
good people get to walk around I walked
past one of them that we just put up the
other day and I got you know he paid off
ninety three thousand dollars in student
loans and the note was Suck It Sallie
Mae
I was cracking up
that's it give old Sallie Mae the old
eviction notice put the old woman in the
street she ain't paying her rent she
needs to go
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones this hour at triple eight eight
two five five two two five in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt free
stage Greg and Amber are with us hi Greg
and Amber how are you hey we're doing
great thank you good to have you guys
where do y'all live
uh Fort Wayne Indiana oh cool welcome to
Nashville and all the way here to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off uh 134 000. excellent how long did
that take uh 30 months good for you and
your range of income during that two and
a half years
uh we started about a hundred thousand
and we'll be at about 180 000 this year
whoa what do y'all do for a living uh so
I'm a sales engineer I'm a registered
nurse ah okay all the work you want huh
pretty much oh and some more yeah Wow
way to go guys okay what kind of debt
was the 134
uh what was the majority student loans
about 80 000 in student loans and we had
a van payment in there
um basement yeah we had to fix our
basement we bought a new house had to
fix the basement
um dog surgery medical bills a little
bit of credit card wow good for you guys
so what was the wake-up call what got
you going on this
well I I we really got intense
um
about two and a half years ago but it
all started I think in 2008 uh we were
married we'd been married a few years
um I had a good job I got laid off uh
the re when the recession hit I got laid
off
um and that was really scary moment for
us we right after I got laid off we
found out we were having our first our
first child
oh that's perfect timing so it was a
really scary I was really terrifying
um so
after that I mean I worked any job I
could I worked I worked night shift
remodeling a Walmart store and we really
worked for the next 10 years to kind of
get back to where we were we
lost everything we almost lost our house
to foreclosure luckily we didn't
um and then in 2015 we took the the
Ramsey Solutions uh course at a church
Financial Peace University yeah
Financial Peace University okay
um we were kind of daveish for for a
while we would be on board and something
would happen and we would you know we
would fall off the wagon yeah but what
what happened 30 months ago because you
turned it up man you went in you went
game on yep so what happened so January
2020 we decided we're going to do it
yeah we got the every dollar app we were
going forward and then uh covet hit and
it felt an awful lot like 2008. and we
did not want to do that again so
uh amber went back to work we worked as
hard as we could and we just uh we just
kicked it into high gear and said no
more so not this time not this time this
time when he comes around we're going to
kick it yes and uh and it resulted in
everything being cleared out in 30
months yes yes okay so the income jump
was that you Amber working during covid
just picking up shifts like crazy yeah I
essentially took a weekend but I work
every weekend every weekend night
um and that was really the only thing
that worked with we also homeschool so
that was the best way to work with our
schedule yeah I can homeschool the kids
and then Greg travels a lot for his job
so it kind of keeps them stability and
then I go into work Friday night and
come back yeah with six kids with six
kids you can't do it any other way so
yeah that's that's very real good for
you guys well done y'all well done are
you tired yes yeah
especially with six kids but it was all
worth it okay so what did we ever go
back in debt no
never I'm done yeah I'm done are you
gonna play on through now and become
wealthy oh yeah yeah good yep good I
want you to be baby steps millionaires
I'm proud of y'all that's our goal yeah
well done you guys I love that you took
the fear that you felt in 2008 you saw
2020 coming and you took that fear and
you just went to action instead of
curling back instead of living in the
fear you used it to push you forward and
really push ahead yeah that's just
incredible what other things did y'all
do to get out of debt so you worked like
crazy did you just buckle down I mean
having six kids that's that's a lot of
groceries it is yeah grocery bills
astounding
yeah uh yeah we yeah we have we have a
lot of groceries
um but yeah I mean it was really we we
worked she worked every weekend so we
didn't see each other very much
um I didn't have I mean go anywhere we
didn't really do anything so it kind of
worked out and we just yeah we buckled
down cut the budget as much as we could
yeah
it's very exciting y'all y'all are
awesome did people think you were crazy
in the midst of this like in the midst
of everybody hunkering down and hiding
you guys are out there just going for it
did people think you were nuts
I think there's already a stigma
attached when you have as many children
as we do and homeschooling and and it's
just like we don't care it comes with
the package
that's funny that's good I like that we
already did stick money
who are your biggest cheerleaders
uh well each other yeah our kids for
sure
um and then our parents our parents
helped out a lot watching when we did
have something on the weekends you know
the helping out watch the kids and when
I was working during the week in Amber
needed help so yeah that's good good
moms and dads that's good stuff good
grandparents excellent job you guys well
done well done well we've got a copy of
The Total Money Makeover for you of the
baby steps millionaires book for you
both number one bestsellers if you've
read them give them away if you haven't
read them read them and then give them
away and also a one-year subscription to
Financial Peace University the new
version with the new videos in it and if
you want to go through it that's fine if
you want to give it away that's fine so
it's all for you guys it's the live and
give bundle there for you and let's
bring the kiddos up give us their names
and ages okay so we have Noah who's 13.
we have Jack who's nine Sam is eight uh
David six Esther's four Andrews two and
then we have a new one due in March all
right we'll have a bigger family wow
that's fun good for you guys well done
well done I do I do want you to speak
really quick to the parents who have
several kids who are drowning in debt
and feel like they can't do it what
would you say to them
it you can do it yeah you can do it it
just takes you just work hard and get
sick and tired of being sick and tired I
guess that's yeah it's tiring but you
can do it yeah you guys are walking
proof of that yeah just continue to be
faithful even in the small things that's
where it adds up yeah
well done you guys good work good work
all right Greg and Amber and the crew
from Fort Wayne I love it 134 000 paid
off in 30 months making 100 to 180 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
you guys ready
all right three two one
[Applause]
I love it wow so good
we do hear that from time to time well
the Ramsey stuff doesn't work for large
families and then we often have large
families on the debt-free stage doing
their screams so it is completely
possible it is a different Dynamic but
so is everything when you have a large
family yeah I mean supper is a different
Dynamic grocery store is a different
Dynamic car ride is a different Dynamic
so that that but you learn to live with
that and you learn to live life well
with that because that's a life of
abundance you've got an abundance of
children you have to have a life of
abundance in the other areas of your
life as well and you have to view it
that way instead of like uh well large
families are cursed because sometimes
it's almost like under the undertone is
like well you know you can't build
wealth and you can't be debt free and
you can't be on a budget if you ever you
know it's always this whiny thing when
people are saying you know they're
hating on us on Ramsay saying you can't
do this stuff and so you're I appreciate
you pointing that out that this is a a
family that did do this and they did it
I mean in 30 freaking months much and
they have worked a lot of hours a lot of
hours and I love that she actually
embraced it it was it wasn't a bad thing
it was actually like this is part of our
weird this is part of like it's the
opposite of making us feel weird it's
we've embraced stigma we've embraced it
we tell people not to be normal to be
weird and she's like we already were
we're doing it you know I mean I like
that that's perfect that's a you know
weird is a good thing because you don't
want to be normal in this culture look
around look what normal is you don't be
normal normal sucks and those guys are
weird in the best possible way the best
way the best possible way some beautiful
kiddos there and uh and 134 000 paid off
in 30 months mic drop baby very well
done this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five a federal appeals court has
temporarily blocked President Biden's
student loan forgiveness plan halting
any debt from being erased but the
administration is encouraging people to
continue submitting their applications
the Friday evening ruling comes less
than a week since the application portal
went live already nearly 22 million
people more than half of qualifying
buyers have signed up the administration
could have begun processing applications
and changing loan balances beginning
Sunday the order does not reverse the
trial Court's dismissal of the case or
suggest that the case is Merit the White
House Press Secretary said in a
statement the block was issued by the
U.S eighth Circuit Court of Appeals
which is considering a motion from Six
republican-led States to stop the
forgiveness program it's one of several
lawsuits that have aimed to challenge
the program
Six States Arkansas Missouri Nebraska
Iowa Kansas and South Carolina filed a
lawsuit arguing the federal relief
program would hurt state-based loan
companies that manage some of the loans
themselves earlier this week a federal
judge dismissed the case saying it as no
standing the group then appealed and
that's the federal appeals court to
place a temporary hold on the program
while the appeals court reviews the case
one of two things can happen in the
upcoming days either the court can issue
an injunction and the pause will last
longer or it can dismiss the case the
program can carry on the federal appeals
court is expected to announce a ruling
as early as next week
oh man I've been saying for a while
buckle up y'all this is going to get
interesting and it is interesting right
now
there's a lot of feelings a lot of
emotions out there I mean 22 million
people have already applied and are
counting on it but at the same time
there's this block and the pause is
coming to an end January 1st so people
are really wondering what's going to
happen I would be very curious to know
your thoughts Dave
well it's not a conspiracy theory it's
just a political chessboard
playing with people's real lives
people's lives are always on the end of
the political chess board but the
political chess board is this
I told you
uh last spring in March to expect
President Biden to issue some kind of
student loan forgiveness just in time
for the midterms yep
to prop his little political butt up
um because he's a failed president by
any standards you have to be extremely
left-wing to think that weekend that
Bernie is working up there okay it's you
just got to be off your rocker now it's
gotten out the cat's out of the bag it's
a mess and uh the you know most polls
are showing us that these midterms are
going to be a bloodbath but aside from
that I'm not a political analyst but if
I were doing politics if I were in
Biden's shoes I would have done exactly
what he's doing I think it's brilliant
um one of the few brilliant things he's
actually done but um brilliant
absolutely brilliant to issue a student
loan forgiveness program knowing that
it's going to be challenged knowing that
there's some question of the
constitutionality that the president has
the power to do this without Congress
approving a half a trillion dollar
ouch
forgiveness program without congress's
approval an unprecedented
for a president to be able to pull this
off
many scholars say unconstitutional but
I've yet to see a constitutional
challenge come through this is not a
constitutional challenge it's a
challenge on the other basis so uh what
am I not a legal scholar obviously so
um you know but from a political
chessboard standpoint he issued it and
here's here's what was going to happen
either it was going to just Sail on
through
and he gets the credit for having the
political cred for having forgiven
people's loans and buys their votes
which is his game plan or the amino
Republicans stop him and these are
Republican Governors at these states
these are Republican states that have
gone against him and so if it gets
blocked and people don't get the
Forgiveness he's in a perfect seat to
blame the Republicans see I tried to
help you people but the Republicans hate
The Working Man and that's all he's you
know he set this up so perfectly in the
timing I mean now this circuit court has
to rule on it the week before the
midterm elections oh
I mean the week of midterm elections
like maybe you know it's uh two weeks
from today
November 8th yeah so uh as we're doing
this show live at this moment that's
that's the situation so as a political
chess board his timing was perfect and
his play was perfect because the
Republicans had no upside to this they
come off looking like the old meanie
that doesn't want their student loans
forgiven or they let this slide through
and we have another half a trillion
dollars hit the books because you can't
forgive loans you have to pay them off
the money comes from somewhere these
banks have to get their money they're
going to get their money I mean the
federal government is paying off the
loans
that's then paying off the ten thousand
dollars worth loans so that means
national debt is going up again by
another half a trillion dollars in an
inflationary economy we continue to suck
cash out of the money supply and uh so
it's it's a political like you said
buckle up it's a political ride now you
can disagree with my uh political
ascertainment or whatever you want but
you got to admit whether you love Biden
or whether you don't in terms of
political chess board it was it was
brilliantly played yeah and its timing
is perfect and I also said expect
whatever he does to look like it's a big
deal but it won't be a big deal I said
that in March you said it I remember it
and guess what it's not a big day it's a
big deal because of the total amount of
money but to an individual that has 90
000 in student loan debt for giving ten
thousand dollars in student loan debt
does not fix your life
on the contrary it makes you want to sit
on your butt again and wait on
Washington to forgive the rest of it
that's what you're trying to do
meanwhile the bozos up there keep making
these loans that are so evil that we
must forgive them and yet we keep making
them that's intellectually dishonest as
it can be
so how do you keep a student loan
program in place that's harming the
American public so much so that it must
be forgiven and keep making the loans
that's completely intellectually
dishonest and that tells you that this
is politics odd infinitum and see here's
the they still have not answered the
questions okay you can file an
application
and this idea that they're going to
forgive the loans by Sunday is
absolutely bull crap because the at the
the loan forgiveness program announced
by the White House says that you have to
make less than 125 thousand dollars
what year
last year
well that's a good question and they're
not even requiring additional how are
you how are they proving like I I
promise I promise I didn't make more
than 125 000. you don't have to turn in
tax returns
you don't I mean how are you proving
your income
they they're taking your word for it
dang I don't think so so I think there's
some other stuff this is uh this is not
the last we've heard from this it's
going to continue on it is a um
it's um it's a bit of a mesh it's a mess
but what would you tell all the people
who in their minds this is already a
done deal who who are counting on this
and I mean they don't they don't see any
chance that this could not happen well
these would be these people would fall
into two categories naive people that
are young
and unbelievably naive people that are
old
because if you're young I I can
appreciate that you've not been screwed
by your government yet and so this is
your first time on this trip when you're
old like me you've been like they've
promised me stuff before you know and so
far none of the success in old Dave
Ramsey's life has come as a result of
anything Washington has done as a matter
of fact it's been all in spite of
everything Washington has done and
that's both freaking parties so uh never
Santa Claus don't live in DC I know the
old guy he lives in the North Pole and
he ain't there and so you're waiting on
the government to fix your life darling
your life's gonna suck
when the government says we're here to
help that's like saying hey the DMV line
is short you know I mean come on really
seriously dumber than crud so yeah
please it just means you're naive you're
sweet and I that's nice of you and and
you know I don't mind actually if your
ten thousand dollars is Forgiven it's
not the end of the world uh I hate that
it's all a political thing and it's
obvious political chessboard work it's
obvious it's no question well I think
it's a good it's a good wake-up call for
people who are counting on this
forgiveness to still think about
controlling the controllables and think
about your budget what you control if
these payments happen again in January
forgiveness doesn't go through how are
you going to pay off your loans think
about that now don't wait till the last
minute don't wait till it's due start
thinking about that now
there's also the moral aspect like hey
you borrowed the money
and now a guy who's a welder
[Music]
he owes the money
because it got moved over he didn't have
student loans and he got moved over to
the national debt and we all owe that as
people
this is just immoral this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studio it's the Ramsay show we're dead
as Dom cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Christina Allen's number
one best-selling author and Ramsay
personality is my co-host today as we
answer your questions the phone number
is
888-825-5225 Eric is with us in Omaha hi
Eric welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you very much for taking
my call sure what's up
so uh within the past two years both my
wife and I have had drastic income
increases and we're trying to figure out
if it's more worthwhile in my starter
level homes but entry if you put more
money towards my 98 000 mortgage or to
invest that money into upgrade uh we
don't have anything that needs repaired
but upgrade trying to figure out if the
upgrades will be more fruitful than
paying down uh the mortgage prior to
moving in two to three years maybe
what kind of upgrades
doing some concrete repair possibly just
replacing the deck boards as you know
the lumber prices are nuts right now so
I'm just trying to make my my deck safer
uh lumber prices are not nuts right now
they've come way down
the window okay they were triple and now
they're back to about normal
um yeah I saw there was like a twenty
thousand dollar surcharge on building a
new house right now so we're trying to
hold that we're trying to hold out
that's a builder that's still trying to
Gig you even though the prices have come
down so that doesn't mean we need that
Builder I'm not paying any Builder a
twenty thousand dollar surcharge in this
current market there's no need
um this Builder hadn't had the Wake Up
Call yet the phone's ringing
um but so
um
uh concrete and deck boards it doesn't
sound like you're spending a lot of
money
the concrete is just Mud Jacking jacking
for for the concrete work on
for that bud hey What's the total bill
on what we're discussing here
two thousand dollar two to three to try
to do it myself
uh but I'm just trying to figure out if
the home upgrades are more fruitful than
paying down my mortgage so I have more
Equity I got that but I'm trying to
figure out what you're spending on the
upgrade so I can answer that
um and 18 000 versus 2 000 on a deck for
labor only do is the difference there's
something screwy about that number
sixteen thousand dollars in labor to fix
a deck
yeah yeah I think that guy was smoking
weed
or something else
um so no I mean if if the Lumber's two
thousand bucks it's not that big a job
you know you can build the debt you
build a debt cheaper than you're talking
about
oh yeah so you need to get you need to
get a different bid because the goober
that gave you the bid on the deck is out
of his cord
and then we're talking about five
thousand dollars to fix the deck versus
two thousand dollars if you put throw in
some labor instead of 16 or 18. so
what's your household income
the household income uh I went from 64
to 110 within the past year and my wife
makes 44. so like 154 I believe gotcha
total okay cool what's the house worth
today
the house is worth uh 240. okay and so
if you spend 20 grand if you spend 20
grand Spruce in this house up 15 grand
sprucing this house up with the broken
concrete and the floating and the
redoing of the deck and that kind of
stuff 10 15 20 grand something like that
you're not going to mess up I would not
spend 80 000 bucks on this house but if
you're going to spend 15 or 20 grand on
it yeah I'll do that let's get the house
fixed up get it living nice and then
make the decision on whether you're
going to sell it or not well and these
sound like they're important upgrades
they're not like adding a pool or you
know something kind of you know that's
that's meaningless these are important
things that even if you want to sell the
house in a few years you're going to
have to do this at some point so you're
gonna have to do it you can't have a
deck you fall through to put the house
on the market yeah so you got to get
that fixed and really the broken
concrete's gonna scare people too so I'd
probably fix all of that and just to get
it ready to sell even if you're gonna
sell it next spring yeah yeah but um I I
think um you're still existing in a one
year ago construction environment
tournament in your head high high lumber
prices High labor prices people smoking
crack that are giving you bids and you
need to go visit again the lumber yard
now because prices are way down you need
to get Revisited on the bids on
everything because the people are um
much more normal now they kind of calm
down they they kind of went crazy for a
while some of them and they've calmed
down now and you're going to get a much
more reasonable uh process probably if
you shop around a little bit from a sub
to do this work and you're going to be
much but yeah do the work and I think
it's a both and do the work and then
attack that 98 000 mortgage like do the
work and then you have this drastic
income increase so keep keep being
intense and intentional about paying off
the mortgage but tackle those repairs
first absolutely Carla is with us in
Seattle hey Carla what's up
hi
um
uh what's up it's raining
how can we help you today
um my question is that my dad and his
wife have asked my husband and I for a
large sum of money to pay off their debt
my husband and I are retired and we are
debt free
but now we are on a fixed limited income
we do not have what they are asking in
the bank
it would require us to take a draw out
of our retirement accounts
and we would not we don't want to do
that
um and I want to respond to dad with
facts and data and not in motion
because I am very emotional and he is a
great salesman
uh so what's your net worth
yeah Untouchable one million or ten
what's your net worth
I don't know exactly my husband knows
the exact numbers oh give me a round
guess
uh I don't know it's two okay two to
three all right and how old are you
I'm I am 56 and he is 57.
and why how much money do they want
55 000 for what
um specific
Ally they say to pay off three credit
cards and a car loan what is the premise
that you should give them fifty five
thousand dollars
just because you're um because you got
some money
um because
um the their statement his statement my
dad's statement was in order to get
ahead and be able to do anything in
their later years they want this debt to
be gone so get a job
[Music]
well she is 80. 80. she is seven it's
already in his later years
I know too late but we have very long
you have we have a lot of longevity and
our family so
um he is expecting to live another 10 to
15 years easy probably it's just so
fascinating and
all right I'm out of time but I have to
answer your question so you hang on
we'll bring you right back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America the
government is planning to hand out more
Biden bucks in the turmo in the form of
student loan forgiveness now but that
forgiveness won't wipe out all your
student loan debt unless you're very
unusual and it certainly won't wipe out
your car dead it won't wipe out the
other things that you've got you need to
actually buckle down and do that we can
show you how to get out of debt we've
shown more people how to get out of debt
so that they can build wealth than
anybody else it's called Financial Peace
University it's a proven plan to pay off
all your loans including your student
loans millions and millions tens of
millions of people have done it so kick
Sallie Mae out kick everybody out that
you owe money to get rid of them and
start Financial Peace University right
now ramseysolutions.com FPU
all right Carla is with us in Seattle
she's in her late 50s she and her
husband are worth somewhere in the
neighborhood of two million dollars her
80 year old father calls with his wife
and says we want 55
000 as a gift from you to pay off our uh
credit cards so that we can do well in
our later years as if he's not already
there and that's a summary of what you
told me is that fair
that's fair he's a good salesman he's a
bit manipulative you have trouble saying
no to your daddy we have established
that and yet you don't want to do this I
think I heard that between the lines and
I kind of think your husband doesn't
want to know for sure
mm-hmm and there are reasons that we
don't what are the reasons yeah
are that
money and she will not pursue it from
her own family
um and so I I feel like they're making
the decision
to be in the situation you're the easier
I am definitely I am so much easier yeah
I'm sorry you're in this situation it's
so hard
even if you're in your 50s you're still
your daddy
and any and it's really hard to own the
fact that he's a manipulative jerk
well he's I well he is
I haven't I haven't even met him but
well you've told me about him I don't
like him
okay who calls up their daughter and
says I'm entitled to 55 000 of your
money and I'm going to send you on a
travel I'm gonna be a travel agent for
guilt trips if you don't give it to me
who does that not the guy I like Carla
what have these conversations look like
how how has he approached you you said
he's a good salesman but what does that
look like or sound like he's always been
in um in sales and jobs his whole entire
life but how it went was he
uh oh by the way when you have a uh some
time this next week can you give me a
call I I want to ask you something I'm
like okay so a few days go by and I call
and I say hey you know I'm calling you
back you said you wanted what do you got
going on and he said well
we we have a situation and he presents
his sales
pitch for why they are asking for what
they're asking
um and they asked a couple other people
before us and now they're asking us and
it would be great
you know all of this would be paid off
they'd pay us this much back over time
and it would be you know
um he he thought that they could pay
back interest which we just kind of you
know like okay yeah whatever no okay and
if the situation or if the situation in
the relationships were completely
different
55 000 out of two million you're not
going to miss it
and no not at all in a heartbeat pay off
my dad or my mom's stuff and just help
out if he's 80 years old but but but the
situation is not different the situation
is what it is and
um and so
um I just you know I'm just gonna have
to tell you what you already know
and give you the courage to do what you
already know you have to do and you
can't live with yourself and your
husband if you do this
so the answer is no
because you're not doing it for any
really good reason you're only doing it
because you're caving
and you're a coward if you do it
am I am I speaking what's been inside
your brain already
um it's not in my brain it's in my
yeah and
and now I'm putting the account in your
brain yeah it tears you up because it's
your daddy
I don't care how old you get still your
daddy and that's why this is just so
wrong
to put you in this position it's just
wrong and so I'm sorry you're there it
does break my breaks my heart for you
but I think you and your husband just
sit down and you say we're going to pan
back from this and this is not a
six-year-old little girl looking for her
daddy looking for her daddy's approval
this is a grown very sophisticated woman
that's very bright in her 50s that is
making a conscious decision to say I'm
not going to be manipulated
thanks
can I follow up that uh no with but here
is a bunch of information from uh Ramsey
Solutions go to this website matter of
fact I'll give you Financial Peace
University
I would love for them I'd love to help
him and help him go through Financial
Peace University I'll give it to you as
a gift well that's very gracious and you
can give it to them well thank you and I
think you and your husband you just say
look we talked about it our money's
taught up in Investments right now we
think you should go after her relatives
money I think that's an easier mark and
it doesn't make sense for us right now
and I love you but I'm just so sorry we
can't do it at this time it doesn't it's
not convenient for us
well what about what about what about
now that that that's the beginning and
the end of it you don't have to give an
explanation to the salesman you just
said no
no I'm not buying the car no I'm not
buying the purse no I'm not buying the
manipulation
no no is a complete sentence
Juan Carla let's get you a copy of own
your past change your future by Dr John
deloney because it doesn't sound like
this is the first time you've had these
type of conversations with your dad it
sounds like there's a history of kind of
manipulative conversation so just taking
some time for you to process that and
heal from that I know it's going to be
hard and you said you've been kind of
lost in your emotions so I'm sure this
is going to be an emotional conversation
it's very hard I mean you're gonna be
you're gonna be you feel like a teenage
girl asking to go out on a date or a
teenage girl that thinks she's going to
get grounded you know it's what that's
that's what it activates inside of you
emotionally I don't care how old I'm 62
and I can feel it right now yeah you
know and I I get that I understand that
so it doesn't go away it doesn't it
doesn't change and so but what you do
the only way to deal with it is to pan
back from the emotions and say okay
we're going to deal with this based on
facts be very gentle and very quick and
short and no is a complete sentence and
it's not a big discussion you do not owe
an encyclopedia worth of reasons
it's our stuff's tied up we don't think
it's a good move and we think you should
get the money from her family and we're
not able to do it right now so right now
we're the answer is now we love you we
hope it works out for you matter of fact
we're going to put you through Financial
Peace University but no yep end of
sentence no more discussion we're not
going to debate this we're not going to
let him drag this down the thing he's
not going to solve the objection because
the objection is over
it's over it's a complete sentence it's
a complete sentence and then you don't
have to feel guilt and shame absolutely
not
and the Very fact that that that's all
here is the reason for the no
exactly it's not her it's not she should
get it from them it's not that um you
have a tied up in Investments it's the
very way that the whole thing is handled
and the whole thing is couched in and
you don't want to do it
and by the way it's your money you do
not have an ethical or a moral
obligation to give manipulators money
just because they happen to begin to you
it's just not there well what about on
the Bible says to honor your parents it
does not say to honor their misbehavior
if your dad calls up and he's doing
cocaine he needs some money you don't
give him money that's not what the
Bible's talking about it says we honor
the position of fatherhood not the
misbehavior of the sole individual that
is in the position
we honor the position of President not
the misbehavior of the president
it's a different thing I honor the
position of motherhood but if mom's an
alcoholic we don't honor that
okay that's the thing you're looking at
and so you're not biblically or morally
or spiritually or psychologically
obligated in any in any sane person's
book
okay so you're set free right now right
now
Hang on we're gonna pick up and get you
FPU for him and on your past change your
future for you this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
's number one best-selling author and
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
Kevin and Lisa are with us in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions and I would ask
where you're from but the Phillies
shirts give you away I'm guessing
Philadelphia yes yes about 15 minutes
away we live in Jersey representing the
representing the team though you're
repping yeah absolutely good job very
cool very cool well done well done well
done all right how much debt have you
guys paid off we paid off 95 146 all
right how long did this take 30 months
good for you and your range of income
during that two and a half years was
about 99 to 125. cool what do y'all do
for a living I work for super for
America in Camden New Jersey I'm a parts
information coordinator all right me
disabled since 2015. okay all right good
so 95
000 worth of what kind of debt it was uh
just about everything we were probably
normal
cards cards most of the animals put us
in debt animals put you in debt what
kind of animals dogs two with diabetes
and overnight stays and every time we
went it was four or five thousand
dollars good Lord yeah and we had a 401k
loan mixed in there and a personal loan
as well okay what was the wake-up call
what got you started two and a half
years ago so we're gonna stop this I
think I think we did it Davis for for a
while and I was at the point where at
least got hurt and we had some issues
going on with that and I got to the
point January 2020. I was going to do a
New Year's resolution and I was going to
get myself out of debt and I came across
you know your YouTube channel and I
started listening and I got I bought in
So Lisa he's kind of gone down the
rabbit hole here on YouTube what did you
say
um I was right with him right with him
right you know let's do it yep we
struggled a lot during the years you
know live in paycheck to pay tax how
long y'all been married 33 years okay
all right together with each other for
40 years okay we were babies we were 14.
okay and you look up and you say all
right after 30 years we're done this has
got to change the worm has turned yes
and you and you went all in then huh yes
we went all in we did everything we
possibly could wow yep what did that
Journey look like I think I had seven
part-time jobs throughout wow just just
you know if I didn't like it I didn't go
back it was just like you know this was
yeah they were everywhere I mean I was I
started at Walgreens I worked at
Walgreens for a little bit I worked at
Walmart I got a job at a floral place
working you know
Monday through Friday it was it was a it
was surreal but you know any and I just
never never thought you'd be a florist
huh no no no
not at all but it was aware it was a
warehouse being a florist I was picking
picking the flowers but they rent boxes
and shipping them to the to the places
that actually made the arrangement so
it's pretty pretty it was pretty cool it
was nice inside it was cool yeah I'll
bet that smelled good too yes yeah we
really had to buckle down once I lost my
salary so yeah yeah are you doing better
are you feeling okay yeah I'm doing okay
good I go day by day good I'm glad y'all
are the definition of gazelle intense
yes yes that's amazing so what would you
tell people is the key to getting out of
debt
budget every dollar budget get it if you
don't if you don't have it I mean it
takes a while to get used to budgeting
but when you're taking three thousand to
four thousand dollars and putting it at
your debt a month and you're you're
having it being able to do it it's
amazing absolutely amazing it is very
amazing way to go you guys you know we
always we never talked about money
before so we sat with meetings every
month every every week you completely
changed yes I mean that's hard that's
hard I think it's easier three months
after you're married than 30 years after
your marriage yeah I think we fought
more married than we did talking these
last few years yeah yeah good good well
and you guys are people who you didn't
budget before you struggled with money
and then you just did it what would you
tell people who are intimidated to
budget it takes it takes work to budget
it does like take three months to to to
hone it down and every dollar now goes
to budgets and we have budget meetings
every month every morning when we're
drinking our coffee you know just saying
this is where it's going when we started
this and we put the thousand dollars
away
I had to hide it every time and keep
putting it away and moving it because I
always thought he was going to take it
I did because for 30 years he had yeah
yeah oh my God and then we really did we
just had to touch it in September his
mom passed away just four weeks ago so
you know and her life wasn't great
because her insurance plan was in her
ex-husbands who was dead and you know we
still have to wait for all that to come
through so we had to dig in that was our
first time we used emergency wow it's
good for you guys it was good how's it
feel to be free awesome fabulous we we
came here we uh we we stayed here for
you know the Friday we got here the
Phillies we're we're playing we were
watching we were watching them and
they're 3-0 since we've been here so I
don't know I might not be able to go
home
throughout the whole world series out
here in Nashville can we stay another
week
yeah so yeah it was pretty good oh who
are your biggest cheerleaders during
this journey are our kids Kyle Kevin uh
and Courtney they knew you needed to do
it and that you could do it we also have
uh probably two weddings coming up in
the next two years so oh yeah
congratulations yeah some things to get
ready for yes very good one I love that
you're changing your family tree the
fact that they are your biggest
cheerleaders they saw what your life
looked like before and then they watched
you fight through this journey you know
that's going to have an impact on them
moving forward yes they see it more now
they didn't see it back then but they
know now yeah that's powerful way to go
you guys I'm so proud of you thank you
very very well done very well done and
you were holding the gazelle card up out
there earlier yes you already got the
gazelle card I got it we just got it as
we were heading out this week so I love
it that's perfect timing cool very cool
well congratulations guys we got a copy
of Money Makeover for you and the baby
steps Millionaire's book for you that's
the next chapter in your story for sure
and uh one year's membership to
Financial Peace University and the live
and give bundle all of that goes in
there use whatever you want give away
whatever you want but and it's all for
you just to say we're proud of you and
way to go so very very well done Kevin
and Lisa 95
000 paid off in 30 months making 99 to
125 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one we're debt free
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
100 of the people who get out of debt
have to overcome things while they are
getting out of that she obviously we
didn't dig for details just out of
politeness obviously went through an
injury and a disability uh as a result
they went through a bunch of other stuff
they did this during covid our last two
debt free screamers right decided in
January of 2020 and then two months
later things start shutting down three
months later the entire world shuts down
and people lose their jobs people are
scared uh their people think you're
crazy if you're out there moving around
and you're working in the middle of all
that and they did anyway
I love that I just kind of have that
visual image of so many people running
away from the storm and instead they
just ran into it you all saw challenges
and you went you know what I'm not
afraid I'm going to go ahead and I'm
going to fight to get our family out of
debt yeah this is it's time that this
changed and uh it's time that this is
over and you have to have that moment
and there's that I've had it moment as
the great motivator Les Brown says you
know you change your life when you
finally say I
I've and that's the thing or you got to
have that moment and it doesn't matter
where you are whether you're 23 whether
you're 63 whether you're 43 I don't care
where you are you've got to have that
moment and the weird thing is different
things will cause you to have that
moment it can be it could have been the
scare around covet it could be uh the
scare around medical problems it could
be uh just I finally am disgusted you
know it doesn't have to be some big
thing but you do need to be able to
pinpoint and go that's when it happened
that's when everything changed it's so
good and and that will Propel you
forward through challenges because it
doesn't sound like your journey was easy
seven jobs you guys had to work hard to
do that you guys had to fight through
you know not feeling like you were
strong at budgeting like you said it
took three months or more to figure that
out you had some arguments and had to
wrestle through it but you did it yeah
you did beautiful good people good
people right there well done Kevin and
Lisa
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christine Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host joining us is the next number
one best-selling author will godera my
good friend from New York has got a
brand new book out and this is a
remarkable book a remarkable man and got
to meet him a few years ago Simon sinek
introduced us as a matter of fact at an
event we were both at in Aspen and we
become fast friends ever since and
you're gonna love this guy you're gonna
love the book the book is unreasonable
Hospitality the remarkable power of
giving people more than they expect
Will's uh ownership uh partial ownership
with 11 Madison Park in New York City
the creativity that he brought to
unreasonable Hospitality made it the
number one restaurant in the world
literally multiple times over and uh has
got multiple Awards after his name
everyone in the restaurant world knows
well and unreasonable hospitality and
knows his personality welcome my friend
thank you so much congratulations
officially there's nowhere I'd rather be
than here with you guys today
oh man that's amazing so what is
unreasonable Hospitality uh give some
examples of what you did at the
restaurant so in reasonable hospitality
is the strategy that I used to make our
restaurant number one in the world all
the other restaurants they they were
unreasonable in the food that they were
serving they were unreasonable in
pursuit of product I choose to be
unreasonable in pursuit of people and
how we made them feel and so we would
basically when I say unreasonable I mean
doing whatever it takes some bizarre
stuff well we so we had a position in
the restaurant whose only responsibility
was to just go way above and beyond so
like one example a couple came in after
their Beach vacation flight was canceled
um we turned our private dining room
into their own private beach we put
about 500 pounds of sand on the ground
and the kiddie pool filled with water
they could dip their feet into over
tropical Mai Tais
um that's amazing or one time we there
was a family of four from Spain visiting
the restaurant and the most beautiful
thing happened when the kids were
looking out the windows with Wonder
because it had started snowing and it
was the first time they'd seen snow
so we somehow found a store that was
still open at eight o'clock on a Friday
night selling sleds and when they left
the restaurant there was a chauffeur
driven SUV to take them to Central Park
to go sledding
um we did all these things who does that
the number one restaurant in the world
that's who does that yeah but I'll tell
you why we didn't listen people don't
collect stuff anymore they don't cost
that much no it does definitely doesn't
it costs ideas and the person's position
their job their title position was they
were called the Dreamweaver yeah I'm not
the 80s rock yeah not to the to the the
seminal song by Gary Wright you know
people don't collect things anymore they
collect experiences and I believe that
in order for an experience to be worth
collecting you need to get people a
memory to help them relive it but the
cool thing and this is what's so special
about unreasonable hospitality and why I
believe it applies to things far beyond
restaurants
is because two things happen when you
create a culture when you give your team
the permission and the resources to
start thinking like this one they're
empowered in my restaurant they were no
longer just serving plates of food that
someone else had created they were
coming up with their own ideas and those
ideas were affecting the experience and
they worked that much hard order to make
the experience great because of it
but two
there's just nothing more energizing
than seeing the look of complete Joy on
someone's face when they receive a gift
you're responsible for giving them yeah
surprising Delight is the best reward
for any team member when they get the
opportunity to surprise and Delight a
customer you're giving them the gift of
being able to give people gifts yeah
um so that's that's a lot of what we did
and it took us straight to the top
that's amazing I remember you talking at
entree Leadership Summit and telling the
hot dog story and about how somebody on
your team just listened and they heard
somebody say you know that was their
dream in New York and you all provided
that yeah we overheard a table saying
that they had had dinner at all the best
restaurants they just hadn't had a hot
dog from a street cart and so we ran
outside grabbed a hot dog somehow
convinced the chef to serve it and
[Laughter]
I would imagine it had some presentation
to it but yeah but I'll tell you what
like when we served it I'd never seen
anyone react to anything we'd served
them the way that they did to that hot
dog because it was specific to them one
of the things I say is that genuine
hospitality is one size fits one where
someone feels seen completely seen
because they they know that you're fully
present with them I think the other
thing the hot dog showed was this lesson
that I believe every customer service
business can benefit from which is take
what you do seriously but don't take
yourself too seriously because too often
in pursuit of these brands that are
somewhat arbitrary in many ways we let
our self-imposed standards get in the
way of us giving people the things they
actually want
well and I think what's happened is
um I'm seeing I think your book timing
is amazing because I'm seeing a Revolt
coming up not only in business but among
the public where they've had enough of
fake friends
fake experiences yeah digital
experiences that aren't real you figured
out Facebook friends aren't real friends
yeah they won't come change your tire to
in the morning they won't help you move
on the weekend they must certainly you
know they just don't they're not real
and uh so you can collect all those fake
friends you want or you can collect real
relationships there's a relationship
revolutionary thing the digital thing is
overplayed its hand and not to say
digital is going to go away I'm not
saying that at all but the current use
of it has become so freaking shallow yep
that there's no connectivity like you're
talking about with unreasonable
Hospitality I mean the digital
transformation has almost started to
feel like a race to the bottom and what
people are craving especially after the
last three years is a connection and
people will pay more and be more loyal
if you're the person that starts to give
it to them but by the way this is not
just a work thing it's a life thing oh
yeah
um but I you know I I I'm excited about
the book
for restaurants of course that's the
world that I'm from but I believe that
this can be a really helpful tool to
anyone in any customer service business
because I mean listen it doesn't matter
what you do whether you're in
construction or financial services or
insurance or retail or real estate you
do the same thing that I do
you're in the business of serving other
people
and this is my Call to Arms that we
should just be a bit more unreasonable
in how we serve them yeah and relational
and connection we had some good friends
uh about six or eight weeks ago I guess
just call and say hey you guys come over
for dinner
you know how weird that is
nobody does that anymore I know that's
so that's so 1970. I know wait hold on
we're going to be together like actually
like human beings together at your table
and you're like cooked and stuffed
they're gonna be in intentionally yeah
the television wasn't on there was no
football there was just people sitting
there talking and eating together it was
fabulous I came home I told Sharon we're
doing that more that's like a thing now
but you're right unreasonable
Hospitality it it can be very personal
for sure yeah I'm so excited about this
book I remember the moment I heard you
speak I was like I can't wait to get
this and start practicing it because the
examples you gave of ways that we can
start implementing it we're powerful how
can other people outside of the
restaurant industry start implementing
some of these practices for sure so I I
just recently moved into a new apartment
and I think that's a great like just
opportunity for an example so every time
I bought or rented a new apartment the
real estate agent has at best left me a
bottle of sparkling wine in the fridge
as my thank you slash congratulations
gift and these aren't cheap apartments
[Laughter]
perhaps not and by the way
this is someone with whom I've spent
weeks if not months looking together for
my new home if they've been paying
attention they should know almost every
intimate detail about my life so imagine
instead if the first time we walked into
the place that we chose he overheard my
wife talking about the Nook that she
could see her tell herself doing yoga in
every morning and imagine if when we
moved in instead of that bottle of
sparkling wine there was a yoga mat in
that Nook with a candle and a note that
said welcome to your new home a that'd
be pretty cool B it doesn't cost that
much more than a bottle of sparkling
wine and C it's an insignificant
investment in what will inevitably be a
lifelong relationship I believe it's
simple pattern recognition no matter
what you do
you can find these opportunities to give
people more than they can possibly
expect and if you seize on them it's a
win-win-win because it will make the
business more profitable yes you have to
spend a little bit of money but that hot
dog you're talking about those two
dollars
but two
the guests will be happier they will
come back and three it just makes doing
the job so much more fulfilling yeah and
people are better at their job when
they're having fun doing it you guys see
why will and I became fast friends she's
brilliant and fun to hang out with the
book is unreasonable Hospitality the
remarkable power of giving people more
than they expect I predict it to be a
big best seller thank you don't want to
miss this it's an incredible book I
can't wait to get it home and read it be
sure and check it out anywhere great
books are sold including Amazon that
puts this hour of the Ramsay show in the
books
foreign
[Music]
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Christina
Allen's number one best-selling author
and Ramsay personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five we're going to go
to GT in Roanoke Virginia to start this
hour hi GT how are you
oh I'm I'm all right a little a little
nervous and a little concerned after
checking my credit statement the other
day okay what's up
well I've got over five hundred thousand
dollars in debt and
um I'm getting ready to sell a house but
I just don't know what to do with the
money and I'm worried I made a mistake
okay five hundred thousand dollars in
debt on what
um thirty thousand dollars in truck uh
thirty five thousand on land at the lake
135 000 on the house that we're getting
ready to sell and 350 000 on the house
we just bought okay and what's your
household income
uh 160 to 180 depending on over time
okay all right
yeah I would encourage you to separate
out the debt when you're kind of looking
at it because that is overwhelming when
you're having all of your PR the 350 is
your primary mortgage right
yes it is now we're moving into that one
within the month tell us a little bit
about the house you're about to sell
with a 135 that you mentioned how much
Equity is in that house
uh we've got it under contract for 260.
okay so what did you you've already
closed on the house this 350 that's your
main house right and that's your old
house right
the 350 is the one that we closed on
that we're moving into the other one the
gold house yes how much did you put down
we haven't closed
the 350
uh none
but you're sort of uh
go ahead go ahead how did you do that
um it was a situation where it was about
to be foreclosed on and it was a great
deal it's probably worth five five fifty
and
um we just we the foreclosing Bank
wouldn't allow us to make a contingent
on selling our own home right and so you
just went got a bank loan
yes okay is that is the 350 now on a
permanent mortgage or is it still a bank
loan
permanent okay all right so you're set
up then the other house is sold when you
sell it you've got the money to pay off
the truck and uh the other 35 000 right
yes and you'll be debt free other than
your home
yes okay where's the overwhelm part
uh just seeing half a million dollars in
debt I've never had that much before in
my life okay
so you're doing all this two-step and
you just didn't look at how many
different squares you were stepping on
yeah I guess so yeah and but now once
you finish the dance
it's not overwhelming anymore really
no no I guess not I mean you got 350 000
household house payment that's it
you've got
um another sixty thousand dollars laying
in your checking account that we need to
set some aside for your rainy day funds
your emergency fund let's call that
thirty five thousand and that gives you
30 000 to put on some other stuff
um maybe get your retirement and your
kids college started with some of that
um and so the end of the end of the
story turns out the the wake-up call and
the lesson to be learned it sounds like
is that
the way you went at this left you more
vulnerable than you like to be and I
would agree with you
yeah yeah because there was a moment
here
and we're kind of still sitting in it at
this moment until this house closes the
first house closes there's a moment here
where you're 550 000 in debt and if it
went sideways you'd be messed up
yeah like if the market froze up and you
couldn't sell that other house you'd be
up a Creek right now
yeah yeah I would and so the good news
is it sounds like you're going to get
out by the hair of your chinny chin chin
and end up in actually a good place but
the good news is it scared you enough to
make you concentrate more next time you
were faced with a similar
opportunity to hide the P under a shell
is that am I missing something
no no you're spot on I just like I said
you know once the numbers hit me it you
know it scared me and I was like what if
something goes wrong yep good and
remember that feeling yeah and so next
time you go I you know because I don't
enter I used to do stuff like that all
the time and and to like took my dadgum
head off and I'm you know walking around
you know like a Halloween costume or
something looking for my head it was
gone it just knocked it off and I'm like
geez man my whole life got turned upside
down here I just about I lost everything
I just lost my marriage I lost about it
destroyed my whole freaking world and so
I don't ever I don't even go close to
that stuff anymore and so that can be
your lesson like I kind of overstepped
here you know I I like I was walking
along the edge of the cliff and the
rocks are falling off and I acted like
they weren't and I was singing and
whistling a tune and and I made it back
like safe but I'm not going to take that
path again I don't like being that close
to the edge and that's a good lesson so
just learn the lessons GT that's all I
would tell you yeah and then just use
that the lessons you've learned to
continue forward being responsible with
your finances yeah we're familiar with
the dadgum cliff right exactly you know
that's really what it has come down to
so very very good question and
um so it's a good example and you know
his emotion came up and caught him but
if this had gone sideways and but now
that it's turned out it's really going
to leave him in a very good place a very
reasonable Place she's debt-free
everything but his house greater than
350 000 mortgage with 180 000 income
that's not out of line this is all very
doable okay he ends up in a good place
but this is an example of when he
started this process he doesn't know
that's going to turn out and that's what
caught him and took his breath away
most people don't even bother to have
their breath taken away they just go oh
that's what I planned and that's what
happened here's the debt only works or
buying two houses at one time only works
or doing anything only works when it
works
and most of the time life doesn't work
exactly the way you had it planned
and so that's when it gets your dad gum
head taken off and that's where you get
to experience the borrower as slave to
the lender and a foolish man devours all
he has and
um in the house of the wise our stores
of choice food and oil and these Bible
verses that talk about living on lesson
you make having an emergency fund having
a plan and not being in debt and
that you know that plan works in good
times and in bad times and so uh we had
a call in an earlier hour today where I
told you God do not buy the second house
until the first one is sold remember
that same same scenario here because you
can get caught now good news is GT got
out I'm happy for him happy he didn't
learn the lesson except put his stomach
in his throat without having to learn
the lesson you know that's good that's
good I'm happy that there's no harm no
foul uh I don't wish bad things on
people what I try to do is help you
avoid setting yourself up where bad
things can get you don't let them get
you it's Halloween this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today
best-selling author Ramsay personality
last week we announced our spring
Building Wealth live tour and tickets
are really selling fast the VIP tickets
in Indianapolis and Anaheim sold out
within 48 Hours the Building Wealth live
events are going to walk you through a
simple but proven plan that will help
you save money build wealth and make
smart decisions in this crazy economy
what's happening out there despite what
the news and the internet say it is
still possible join me Rachel Cruz Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney George Campbell
for a night of Hope and normalcy this
spring the tour dates available today
Indianapolis February 16th Austin Texas
February the 23rd and Anaheim on May the
second tickets start at 39 dollars our
fall events sold out in days you do not
want to wait on this go to
ramseysolutions.com events to get your
tickets and particularly you better get
them like today if you want VIP or
platinum on any of these they go first
and they go early and they go really
really fast our question of the day is
from blinds.com they have a 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your window blinds
for free free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal today's
question comes from Trish in Missouri
our son graduated from high school in
2021 he decided to use his scholarships
working income and a small subsidized
Federal Loan to pay for college so far
he has done an amazing job with his
finances he had 17 700 saved for him in
his 529 but he wanted to leave it alone
and use it for his late years of school
when he might need it even more the 521
529 was doing so well we neglected to
look at the funds he was in and move it
to safer funds as he got closer to 18
years old it grew to 18 700 by 2022 but
has dropped significantly to 14 800 as
of today we realize now this was a
mistake now with less than three years
of college left the market still looking
Grim do we move it and cut our losses
tell him to use it all that he can now
or just wait it out also Missouri where
our 529 is as of right now will not let
us use 529 to repay back loans later
thanks for the advice hmm
this is interesting I I feel like the
first thing I would do is just kind of
talk to you guys about your mindset I
mean you're saying that he's taken out
federal subsidized student loans so far
and that he's also doing great with his
finances I think the fact that even debt
was on the table to begin with isn't
great you had a 529 available and then
you still took out a student loan I kind
of would just challenge you first and
foremost to go let's let's not do debt
like let's first establish that mindset
and take it off the table and then
explore options from there I think if
that was kind of a conversation from the
beginning you probably would have used
the 529 earlier on and he wouldn't have
taken out a loan
um but Dave I'm curious about your your
thoughts on this because we're never
going to tell you take out a lot exactly
period okay so now we got to figure it
out because here's what taking out a
loan is in this situation if you're
taking out a loan so that you can leave
this alone and let it come back up
that's like saying I'm going to borrow
14 800 hoping and invested in the stock
market hoping it will go up
well you would never do that that's
Dumber in a rock
and so no we're not going to do that
we're not going to take out a loan in
order to give this time to ride back up
what we are going to do is put Junior to
work
yeah w-o-r-k
I want him busting it and uh I want him
you know using Christina's materials and
applying for scholarships like a
bazillion of them I don't aim to apply
apply apply apply apply I want him
working all the time and um
then the other question I've got is
where is he in school
you know I was in an expensive school
you can't afford so in other words if
you want to leave this money alone and
let it come back up which is a good idea
actually
the only way to do that is find the
money to pay for school
because three years if he's got three
years left that's a lot of time it's
gonna come back up right and you've got
to find the money anyway because this is
not enough to get him through school
well and if they continue going forward
with the way they're going forward three
years of taking out loans is going to
add up to a lot of money like you're
saying that it's a good he's done well
with his finances so far but three more
years of taking out loans that's not
gonna be good so it's amazing the
creative options you come up with when
you take debt off the table he's going
to have to maybe look at what school is
he at can he go to a cheaper school is
there some sort of employer he can work
for that has a tuition assistance
program what scholarships are out there
can he talk to the financial aid office
and see if they can offer him anything
else like when you don't have debt as an
option then you really start fighting
for yourself and trying to figure out
what are the most strategic ways for me
a ton of these retailers like Target for
instance and others are if you're
working a certain number of hours
they're so desperate they're willing to
pay tuition
legit and so yeah go that that and that
changes the numbers on what you're
making while working there I mean you
might be making 18 you might be making
22 an hour and getting free tuition
potentially thousands of dollars in
tuition like that is a lot of benefit
right there plus you're building your
resume I mean you may be starting in a
basic retail position but maybe you can
be a manager by the time you graduate so
if you're not going to borrow any more
money for the next three years you've
got to figure out how do I pay a way to
pay for college anyway
so while you're doing that that gives
you also time to let this money grow
back before you cash it in yep because
I'll tell you that in 12 months I think
you'll be fine it's gonna be back that's
my guess might be 18.
might be 18. but bear markets there's
very few bear markets would have lasted
longer than that when you start this
process the spare Market started
basically at the first of this year
and a four-year bear Market is almost
non-existent in history there's almost
none of them and so you know two years
you're going to be fine 18 months you're
going to be fine something like that
you're going to make some money on this
money but the the point is you've got to
have some money anyway to get through
school without debt and so we need to go
find that money from working from
scholarships and for work scholarships
whatever it is we're doing and from
school choice uh and so forth so you've
got a lot of work to do period across
the board and the book is debt free
degree it is in the Ramsey store at
ramseysolutions.com and it will help you
with this process and Austin if you can
figure out who this person is and how to
send it to them go ahead and send them
one okay I don't know whether what our
connectivity is on all these questions
that come in by email and other things
so but if you can do that get him out
get him one out I'll get her and one out
I guess and but yeah the
it's almost like uh we're doing good
with our money while we borrow student
loans is as dumb a statement as I don't
have any debt oh wait I've got student
loans yeah that's debt
it's just those are both dumb statements
people keep saying that student loans
it's good debt and people just seem like
that that for some reason God people are
starting to realize this bad debt I mean
it's so bad the president has to forgive
it
but still keep giving out loans yeah
well thank you for that that's good yeah
she you ruined the whole thing there
Robert's with us or Robert is in uh New
Hampshire hey Robert what's up
hi guys thanks for taking my call sure
um so me and my wife have been on a
credit card with 35 to 37 000 for the
last 15.
20 years
um wondering if Poland
from my 401k to pay that
is smart or not well you if you don't
change your habits you go right back in
debt wouldn't you
so we don't have we don't have a credit
card problem we got a habit problem
okay with just the one credit card
everything else has been good and we
have a minimizing problem
yes
you call me up because you're stressed
out about your credit cards and you're
like well it's just one okay which one
is it is it a problem or isn't it okay
so no we're not cashing out your 401K
for two reasons one is you got to change
you
and that's the best answer for your
long-term wealth building and two is
um if you cash out your 401K they're
going to charge you a 10 penalty plus
your tax rate so you're going to get hit
30 to 40 percent and so that's like
saying hey Dave I want to borrow money
at 30 interest pay off my credit card I
would of course say no and you would
even say no to that Robert so no we're
not doing it
so the question I'm actually asking do I
take a loan out against Michael no no no
no no no you can't borrow your way out
of that sir doesn't work can't get out
of a hole while you're digging out the
bottom it's time to address Robert
look in the mirror say you're the
problem
in the mirror say you're the solution
hold on I'm going to send you a book
called Total Money Makeover that showed
10 million people fix what you need to
fix this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today number
one best-selling author in the lobby of
Ramsey Solutions on the debt free stage
Brian and Valerie are here hey guys how
are you doing great we're doing awesome
welcome good to have you guys how much
where you guys live Denver Colorado cool
welcome to Nashville thank you how much
have you paid off well married we paid
off 160 000 in 22 months and single or
all together we paid off 205 and 34
months okay before the 22 months started
or is that total including everything uh
for the 22
months so the total is more like uh 365
000. or it's 205 total in 34 months oh
okay that's the total that's what I was
at okay all right so that's a good good
good good good all right and so uh
during the 22 months what was your range
of income it was 213 to 273. all right
very cool what do you guys do for a
living
and I'm a manager for an engineering
firm uh for a cad manager ah okay very
cool kind of figured out how you two met
okay and so um all right and uh so we
had 205 000 total yes and started
working on it before we're married
finished it after we're married tell us
the story how did all this work yeah so
I it started in August 2020 so right or
yeah 2020 right before the pandemic and
uh
or August 2019 and I was in interning as
an engineer before I got my first job
and my good friend Mark who is a marine
reservist just want to point that out so
you can imagine how uh intense he is but
he came into my office and kept trying
to get me to do this Ramsay thing in
this FPU class and I was like no I'm
fine I'm fine and uh finally two weeks
before the class started he came in and
he closed my door and was like why won't
you take this class
and I was I I think I just broke down
crying
yeah
I just broke down
and this is like illegal right here
this is how we do in the armed forces so
he I kind of opened up to him and uh
my family we'd lost four people in four
years
um
and
dealing with PTSD I just gotten out of
the military and I was broke I was in
six figures of debt and I just I was
scared and ashamed and I was making less
than 40 000 with six figures of debt so
and he could see your eyes yeah and he
convinced me to take it and I was pretty
resistant for six weeks it was until the
seventh class that I was like okay I
know you are a hard case
I mean usually first or second class I
guess I mean seven classes I was so
angry especially about the student loans
I was convinced I couldn't go to college
without student loans
that gets you started on the whole thing
and then poor Brian wanders into the
story
it was our first date I was talking
about it and I was like yeah if you're
not on board I'm just not sure about
this you know so our fbu classes became
date night and uh it was the only way I
kept got to keep seeing her so
you went from I'm not going I'm going to
cry about it too uh we're not even going
on a second date if you're not in dude
yeah wow that's this is a what seventh
class was thorough I mean at least the
conversion was thorough but then she was
all in yeah then I was all in and then
some and I think it was Chris Hogan it
was three years ago I think he was in
that one yeah it was his deep voice just
really got me he was like oh I need to
do this so it was very it's very
commanding it is commanding very cool
cool good for you guys so you you
finally get convinced and then you get
started what did the Journey of paying
off the debt look like
um it had its ups and downs
um you know we stuck together and uh we
did our our first budget meeting
um that was that was fun that was six
hours yeah
um six hours yeah I'm a state right yeah
this is two Engineers okay so I'm a nerd
with a spreadsheet he could not give up
the spreadsheet no no not at all and
then um it became easier once we kind of
jumped into the full like we're all on
board we're not doing a Davis
um we got the every dollar app and so
that I had to release control of my
spreadsheets
I think it was but it was it was totally
worth it and you know us being a new
married couple
um financials can be a real struggle and
a real stress on the marriage but
um we went into it knowing we were on
the same plan and uh it just made it's
made our marriage so much more
successful and wonderful
who are your biggest cheerleaders in the
process
well our best friends Lisa and JT came
with us today way to go guys yeah um and
then our FPU coordinators I think
they're listening right now Mary and
Mark oh that Mark was the coordinator
yes yes oh okay he's recruiting for the
class I got it I mean he was all in so I
love it way to go Mark yeah that's
awesome so so you truly experience that
resistance and now yes you are here you
went all in you paid it off so if you
were in Mark's position and you're I
mean you're in his position right now
there are people listening who feel that
same level of resistance what would you
tell them
well I would just tell them for someone
like me who I just I was so I just
thought I was so strong and I could do
this all on my own and
um I was too ashamed and embarrassed
um
to and too prideful to think that I was
doing something wrong and so I just I
think the biggest thing is to be humble
enough to put your pride down
and uh if it's not working for you try
something new
so good yeah it's not like it's your
identity I mean right yeah but people
treat it so yeah we hold on to it was
such a tight fist we do yeah and so that
that whole part of your journey is
actually more beautiful than the paying
off of the debt
I've changed completely
um I was so resistant and so hard-headed
and
now it just feels like I'm a different
person you had so much loss yeah and and
then you had some anger to go with it
yes and you should yeah you had quite a
little chemistry thing going on here I
had a lot going on chemistry said a
little chemistry set going on here I was
just mad all the time yeah yeah and and
then you just aimed you're mad at the
right thing yes and knocked it out yeah
and that there is something that sets
you free when you do that that's very
powerful yes very cool you guys are you
guys are a neat couple and uh what
you've been through and what you've been
through together is very very very
strong you're set up to win at an
unbelievable level now because not only
that but you probably heard us say that
in the millionaire study that we did the
number one uh career choice of
millionaires is engineer and you're and
we have two of them here
yeah and you've been through FPU and
you're thoroughly thoroughly thoroughly
converted by less than seven oh my God
yes yeah I still I still can't get over
that but yeah it's good what a way to
start your marriage like you can just
tell by the way y'all look at each other
that you're so connected yeah yeah
that's just powerful
I love it hey we got a copy of The Total
Money Makeover for you you'll be able to
give that away as you continue to uh
tell people what has happened in your
life we're so proud of you you guys are
amazing amazing couple and of course
baby steps millionaires because that's
the next chapter in your story you write
on your way to that and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
that you can give away as you're talking
about it so the live and give bundle is
just for you guys we're so proud of you
very very very well done all right if
you got to tell people one thing or two
things they got to do to get out of debt
what do you tell them
um I everybody says it's a budget but I
mean it's true you have to stick to it
and don't everybody has a mountain to
climb we we all have doesn't matter how
small or how large it is
um we all have to do it and so just
stick with it stay on the path and
you'll climb that
it's uh one bite at a time right the
elephant that's how you eat the elephant
beautifully done well done Brian and
Valerie Denver Colorado what a great
story 205
000 paid off single and married over 34
months making 213 to 273. count it down
let's hear a dead free scream three two
one
[Applause]
I gotta keep you coming back I love it
baby
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day Romans 14 17
for the kingdom of God is not a matter
of eating and drinking but of
righteousness peace and joy in the Holy
Spirit Mark Twain said to get the full
value of joy you must have someone to
divide it with
ah well done Mark Twain Mark Twain the
Romantic who knew hey folks if you like
this show please do us a favor we need
three favors from you one is subscribe
on YouTube subscribe on the podcast
number two leave a review that would be
a five-star review we don't really need
your one Stars thank you very much and
share it with a friend tell somebody
listen tell somebody jump in be part of
the program be part of a tell them what
it's done for you I mean that young
couple there we got to meet them at the
break absolutely amazing and uh just
powerful stories and uh you guys on
radio
YouTube gets a little bit of glimpse of
it but on radio you didn't get to see
her eyes I mean it just lit up I mean
she's just on fire and uh they they you
know they again they
Financial Peace University
um the podcast that you know the whole
thing and
um and now they're
uh I mean what would you pay to get rid
of 205 000 worth of debt
it's 99 to go through FP I mean this is
like a good trade that's the way I see
it there's a very good Roi yeah it's a
good Roi Daniel is with us in Mobile
Alabama hi Daniel how are you hey I'm
great it's uh honor to be on with you
well thank you sir how can we help
I've got a I've got two questions my
first question is
the way the market is today
I've lost roughly 60 000.
you know yeah I've got a Vanguard Target
retirement account
my question is to stop the bleeding
so you got like a half million dollars
in it
no I had about 225
thousand in it
and I lost 60 000 since when
uh
since about a year in the past year
well the Market's down 13 that wouldn't
be sixty thousand on 220.
well I'm down about 160.
wow so you're down about 60 you set go
down to 160 I see okay yeah yeah okay
all right um I got my question I've been
listening to a lot of things on the
radio and I've talked to a few people
what is your opinion about indexed
annuities
would I be would there be any advantage
to go into something like that just to
stop the bleeding yeah it's too late
I mean you're not stopping the bleeding
unless you think it's going to continue
to bleed out and I don't
um and so the only person that gets hurt
on a roller coaster is one jumps off in
the middle of the ride
and so
um you know uh I'm I'm not sure that I'm
a fan of uh your initial selection of
funds
um but how old are you
six and six okay I'm 62 and I have mine
across four types growth growth and
income aggressive growth and
international and in the last 12 months
the stock market and the Dow Jones has
lost about 13 percent and that's about
what I'm down is about 13 you're down
more than 13 percent
it's what you're telling me so
um I would not move it to indexed
annuities I don't have a diamond indexed
annuities
um and uh
so do you need the money today no okay
um you've got other money yes okay
what's it in
um well
I'm retired
um
of course I've got my teacher retirement
I've gotten a social social security
um I'm debt free
except
if I say a debt
um helping pay for law school for one of
my my daughter okay
so that's really the only thing that I
have that's your only nest egg
uh yes and you're living off of your
teacher pension and stuff okay yeah okay
now I've got
I had about 75 000 just in savings that
I'd been putting some take diverting
some to there to be ready for the Law
School tuition good okay that's fine
yeah that's where it should be that's
good all right um well the the Target
Fund that you have or the target funds
that you have what's the track record on
them long term how old are they
I can't answer that okay I got in about
20.
about 2014.
okay so you've been you've been in eight
years and it's not been a problem it's
just this particular downturn you really
took it on the chin yeah you've written
out a couple other downturns so yes like
spring of 2020 remember that it dropped
like crazy
remember that
for the most most of the time I don't
even look at it okay all right well if
you go back and look
your your fund most funds dropped
substantially around the coveted
quarantine hit
and then they came back in September
or back to where they were they're back
even but a lot of people jumped out with
that down downturn because they're
freaking out over everything over covet
right
um and so right now we got a Biden freak
out going on or whatever you want to
call it inflation freak out
um
and uh corporate profits are down and so
stocks are down
and um because inflation's putting the
squeeze on the profit margins as well as
causing prices to go up so um
ah Daniel no index funds I would not do
to answer your question what I would do
is sit down with a smartvester pro and
um let's do a little bit of learning
because I'm not sure I can answer your
question on it without I want to go back
on this Target Fund and say I've got to
get comfortable with the history of it
that its recovery rate is about as good
as the Market's recovery rate if I get
comfortable with that I'm probably just
going to leave it alone
if I'm uncomfortable that this is a good
selection and I need to move it into
some other funds I'm going to move it
from one set of funds that are down to
another set of funds that are down that
have a better recovery rate when the
market turns up
I got you that's what I would do but no
the index fund is mythology because it
has to ride the other stuff too it's
indexed off the stock market that's what
it's indexed off of and they put some
checks and balances in there and charge
of double commissions uh to where you
think you've got your principal
protected and other stuff it's an
insurance product and so I I wouldn't
screw with it I don't put any money in
that kind of stuff I just ride these
waves and the good news is you don't
have to have the money and you can
afford to ride the wave what you need is
and what I would need if I were you and
I'm asking you to get this is some
intellectual
um
comfort
that the recovery rate on this fund when
the stock market recovers is reasonable
that it's going to come back as the
market comes back meaning that the fund
is riding the market wave not just a bad
fund
um and it's scaring me because it's down
further than the market pretty
substantially so that's why I want you
to look at that if you told me you were
off 13 I'd say I just tell you sit tight
write it because that's what the
Market's off
but when you're down more than 13
percent in in 12 months then if you're
down from 220 to 160 in that period of
time then there's something else going
on here and I want to look at that this
this may be a more volatile fund which
might mean it might recover faster
actually so you just need to learn the
fun so jump on ramseysolutions.com click
on smartvestor Pro and learn because
Christina the trick with this is history
is the only shot you've got at getting
some comfort
on these things I mean if you look at a
phone that's got an 80-year history like
I've owned one that's 80 years old okay
and I can go back and go it's got 11.2
percent rate of return for 80 freaking
years and it's down 13 I can kind of be
calm you know history gives me Comfort
right
um but but if if I don't know those
things then it's harder to be calm yeah
and I think this is such an important
conversation right now to have because I
think a lot of gen Z Millennials who
this is their first time writing out you
know a bear Market a rough Market it's
just important like you said The only
person who gets hurt on a roller coaster
is the person who jumped off you know
it's just important to be able to look
historically you know what are these
markets like and then just look at the
funds and see the history see the track
record and then have peace As you move
forward and not freak out and jump off
the great news is that Daniel can live
on his pension and he can just leave
this alone and it can afford to let it
ride back up that's the great news in
this call so very well done very well
done that puts this hour of the Ramsey
Show in the books our thanks to Austin
Ben Zach Andrew and James in the booth I
am Dave Ramsey Christina Ellis my
co-host will be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]